[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
réformer l'audiovisuel public
développement des plateformes numériques
réseaux sociaux télévision connectée le
secteur de l'audiovisuel a récemment
traversé de profondes mutations le cadre
législatif posé en 1986 pour réguler un
univers strictement national à une
époque ou internet n'existait pas ne
paraît plus adapté face à ce constat
Laurent Lafon a déposé en avril dernier
une proposition de loi relative à la
réforme de l'audiovisuel public et à la
souveraineté audiovisuelle son texte
repose sur deux piliers
il propose tout d'abord un regroupement
de l'audiovisuel public visant à créer
une offre de programme gratuite de
qualité accessible à tous et surtout les
supports
concrètement une société holding appelée
France média serait mise en place et
définirait les orientations stratégiques
de France Télévisions Radio France
France médias mondelina en complément le
texte entend réviser la loi du 30
septembre 1986 relative à la liberté de
communication par exemple il est temps
aux plateformes l'obligation de céder à
des services de télévision en accès
libre certains droits relatifs à des
événements sportifs d'importance majeure
mardi 13 juin 2023 le Sénat a adopté
cette proposition de loi après avoir
précisé et complété ces dispositions
afin de renforcer l'indépendance de
l'audiovisuel public le Sénat propose
ainsi que soit nommé un administrateur
indépendant dans les conseils
d'administration des sociétés de
l'audiovisuel public
par ailleurs le texte prévoit plusieurs
mesures visant à préserver la
souveraineté audiovisuelle
cela passe notamment par un renforcement
des pouvoirs de l'Autorité de régulation
et la désignation d'un tiers indépendant
pour définir les méthodes de mesure de
l'audience des plateformes afin de
garantir la fiabilité des données la
proposition de loi est désormais
transmise à l'Assemblée nationale
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]